bonjour armand de redange et merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors ce
report des jeux olympiques une première
historique en temps de paix mais ce
n'est pas vraiment une surprise
bonsoir oui bien sûr c'est pas une
surprise n'est pas du tout c'est inédit
totalement ne s'est pas une surprise car
la décision était prise depuis un
certain temps déjà
la seule surprise qu'on peut avoir c'est
le sel blanc de la part du cio
le cio a entendu beaucoup de temps pour
donner cette nouvelle totalement inédit
l'équidé d'inévitables est attendu
effectivement que l'om elle sait que les
japonais prennent leurs responsabilités
quant au report de ces jeux mais cela
avant les conséquences très très
important lorsque le président a dit
qu'il n'y a pas de considérations
financières n'ai eu que des
considérations sanitaires
non il ya eu des considérations
sanitaires importants et ça c'est un
point acquis le diamant il ya
considération important de la part de la
pression
l'ensemble des acteurs vous olympique à
commencer par les athlètes ensuite par
les comités la solara puis ensuite dans
les fédérations
ensuite par les médias ensuite par les
sponsors
donc il y avait une pression énorme pour
le seuil haut mais il hésitait encore
donc là à ce niveau là on peut féliciter
le gouvernement japonais d'avoir pris
ses responsabilités mais la décision
finale qui appartiennent celio elle a
été faite sous pression mais là c'est
assez inquiétant
et qu'est ce qui justement a fait
hésiter le gouvernement japonais presque
jusqu'à la dernière minute en hausse et
de grandes compétitions ont été annulés
l'euro de football des grands prix de
formule 1 le tour d'italie
c'était vraiment la dernière compétition
qui reste elle et les japonais ont
essayé de tenir jusqu'au bout dans les
japonais sont des langues sont des
personnages très très sérieuses à ce que
c'est que de affronter des qu'attaquer
s'il ya eu des multiples au delà même de
du report des jeunes les considérations
économiques ou l'image du pays une
considération politique était importante
mais le sait mais le japon dès le départ
il ya environ des belles de parcours il
ya deux semaines savait que le problème
se pose et il fallait trouver la formule
la meilleure que du communication n'est
pas laid que soit le japon le 10 soit le
seuil
ils n'ont pas encore le japon la paix
comment quid d'un forcément de de ce
report d'un an des jeux olympiques
quelle conséquence tout simplement
économique les conséquences économiques
sont très importantes pour nos amis
japonais ont par le désir d'une chute
d'un point du pib au delà des
difficultés liées aux fléaux sanitaires
liés aux problèmes des jeux avant les
jeux l'organisation elle-même où tu es
prêt de 20 milliards
les retombées estimées à plus de 40
milliards donc à partir de là tout cela
tombe à l'eau mais autre chose qui aussi
pause grand problème c'est qu'en 2021
on reporte du matin ce qui tue le bonne
décision mais pour pouvoir organiser ces
jo du 21 il sera nécessaire de se mettre
d'accord avec l'ensemble des acteurs du
monde sportif qui organise des tas
d'événements à ce moment là donc ça va
être assez compliqué d'autant plus que
dans la foulée derrière lui mois plus
tard sont prévues les jeux de pékin
et puis trois ans plus tard les jeux de
paris puis cinq ans plus tard les jeux
de milan où les yeux du maire tout ça
fait beaucoup
dans une période relativement courte à
la fois pour les médias à la fois pour
les sponsors mais sera aussi une
conséquence importante
quant à la gouvernance du sport mondial
à venir perdre jusqu'à maintenant on
avait toujours l'impression et à juste
titre que c'est le cio qui dirigeait le
moment international là aujourd'hui
par cette décision a été prise par
ailleurs eh bien il est père aujourd'hui
effectivement ces différents acteurs ont
joué un rôle très important au sein de
cette gouvernance et le sera sans doute
plus pyramidale
merci beaucoup armand de rodange et
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes consultant
international du mouvement olympique
merci beaucoup